[Musique]
midi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
notre invité aujourd'hui est ce qu'on
peut appeler de manière un peu triviale
une machine à tubes on peut
difficilement dire autre chose il a
composé plus de 2000 chansons il a écrit
pour les plus grands johnny hallyday
dalida sardou patricia kaas céline dion
et attention je ne vous parle pas de
titre confidentiel rester dans les
placards des maisons disent que non non
je vous parle de cartons que les radios
diffusent encore 20 ans 30 ans après
leur sortie est ce que tu viens pour les
vacances c'est lui je te survivrai c'est
lui aussi elle préfère l'amour en mer il
tape sur les bambous c'est encore lui
mon mec à moi mademoiselle chante le
blues c'est toujours lui et je pourrais
ne pas m'arrêter bien sûr il a eu aussi
ses propres succès de chanteurs si je
vous dis à toutes les filles que j'ai
aimé avant non seulement vous
reconnaissez tout de suite mais je suis
sûr que vous aurez l'air toute la
journée en tête sa recette il ne nous
l'a donnera pas probablement parce qu'il
ne l'a pas lui-même en revanche qu'est
ce que ça dit d'un auteur lorsqu il
colle à ce point à la tente du public
qu'il écoute les autres qu'il est en
phase avec les gens ou du moins qu'il
l'a été posons lui toutes ces questions
bienvenue dans un monde un regard
bienvenue didier barbelivien merci
partage dans ce cas avec nous ici au
tournant au sénat tant de des
compléments sur moi j'ai envie de
revenir d'hommes mais voilà on va
recommencer en tout cas on a dû vous
poser la question forcément mille fois
sur la recette du tube donc ces
questions que moi je ne vous poserai pas
parce que probablement que vous ne
l'avez pas la recette en revanche vous
l'avez peut-être analyser ce succès avec
les années peut-être avez-vous compris
que vous étiez en phase avec les
français que vouloir offriez quelque
chose qu'ils attendaient de la légèreté
non c'est plutôt que les français ont
enfin je leur dois plutôt de la
reconnaissance parce que c'est eux qui
ont fait le succès maintenant non les
recettes non les seules recettes que je
connaisse c'est mes copains cuisinait
qui me les font passer de temps en temps
mais c'est vraiment gentil non les
chansons c'est plutôt un truc spontanée
peut-être dans l'air du temps enfin moi
je me suis jamais posé la question de
mes chansons faire chauffer sa com
sociale plus naturellement possible mais
vous sentez bien
les français les français trouvent vos
chansons peut-être réconfortante il n'ya
pas non plus de textes très clivant
c'est peut-être ça aussi qui viennent
chercher chez vous
je sais pas moi j'essaie de rester dans
le registre de la variété quand j'écris
des chansons alors que mes auteurs
préférés sont peut-être enfin ne sais
pas peut-être c'est sûr léo ferré
georges brassens jean ferrat oui de
voiliers des mecs un peu
way qui la ramène carrément à travers à
travers leurs chansons et je trouve que
c'est très talentueux de savoir écrire
des chansons aussi forte que nuit et
brouillard je pense à ferrat ou
ou même dans un autre jean miss maguy de
renault j'avais bien kiffé de ça déjà
mais s'il faut démêler auteur engagé des
chansonniers engagé mais de ne pas
soi-même et crytek je me suis essayée au
une ou deux fois ce gens là et je trouve
ça ridicule de fait par mois je trouvais
ça très didactique je me dis mais t'as
aucun talent mon pauvre pour écrire des
trucs comme ça
donc non je me suis contenté d'écouter
des autres et
d'y prendre du plaisir et donner du
plaisir aux autres on va écouter
quelques chansons si vous êtes d'accord
d'abord les paroles
au hasard elle préfère l'amour en mer
que vous avez écrites et composées pour
philippe lavil si longtemps dans cette
histoire brunch quelques quelques
paroles
la marine en est fier
[Musique]
on a on a un peu de recul aujourd'hui
alors je renie les paroles pour les gens
qui nous écoutent d'amour en est je suis
tombé d'une histoire vraie ah bon enfin
je sais pas si on peut dire ça sur cette
chaîne mais j'avais une publie une
public une une amie à l'époque
comment je pourrais le dire élégamment
on peut tout dire sur cette chaîne très
émoustillé par le mouvement des vagues
de la mer d'accord voyez ça lui évoqué
des trucs chez pas enfin était inquiet
salam était de bonne humeur ont très
bien vous pensez que vous pourriez
encore écrire des choses comme ça
aujourd'hui que ça ne ferait pas
polémique qu'elle ferait peut-être jugé
sexiste à certains égards c'est possible
alors franchement je me suis jamais posé
la question
de
quelconque censure ou d'une quelconque
arrière pensées sur sur ses chansons
n'ont jamais
même nom j'ai dû écrire des trucs même
ambiguë quelquefois mais pas forcément
à connotation sexuelle je peux écrire
des trucs ambigu dans le sens est ce que
le public a bien compris de gauche park
par exemple je me souviens de l'été sera
chaud qui faisait chanter la france en
détestera chaud c'était quand même un
des slogans qu'on lisait sur les murs en
l'été 68
dans les banlieues oui c'était forcément
l'été sera chaud dans les t-shirts dans
les maillots s'est fait plus c'est l'été
sera chaud
préparez vous à la rentrée il y en avait
1 que j'adorais aussi qui disait
milliardaire de tous les pays unissez
vous il y en a plus pour longtemps
j'adore respire ok mais quand même un
peu de politique dans certaines on va
écouter d'autres d'autres paroles études
ans avec lui interprété par sait gérer
[Musique]
c'est du vécu aussi ça je m'en rends
compte jean bernard en les réécoutant
je me dis comment j'ai eu cette idée
parce que je me dis je ne pouvais
peut-être c'est la question vous allez
me pose est donc j'anticipe céline côté
georges marchais d'attention ce père à
des questions surprenantes 70 jean marc
sahi ce qu'ils faisaient
journaliste tu disais c'est pas mauvais
ce n'est pas ma question monsieur
marchait je le regardais du 0 m/s ma
réponse non mais cela dit à une histoire
autour de cette chanson avec saint
jérôme qui la refusent au départ je
crois et non non non non ce des
mauvaises légende ça alors évitez les
rebelles n'ont aidé à refuse pas on
avait perdu la chanson de c'est autre
chose on l'avait garée en tout cas ils
sont là ils garent et 118 7 ans pas mal
c'est ça et c'est une chanson qui va
lancer relancer sa carrière qui va le
ramener au devant de la scène et ouais
c'est devenu un gros succès de l'année
85 il ya beaucoup d'artistes qui vous
doivent béraud d'une certaine manière
les retours non leur carrière et arrière
à part patricia kaas mais
pétrie ses caisses vous doit sa carrière
le début oui mais évidemment
après bon ça a tourné un peu court mais
c'est plus de son fait que du bien mais
pourquoi qu'est ce qui s'est passé parce
que c'est intéressant cette relation
entre ce parce qu'après je
l'attendais les chansons avec la maison
de disques qui voulait absolument
s'entendre sur nrj il veut savoir dans
la profession il ya des gens qui
écrivent des chansons
stéréotypé pour passer sur telle radio
oh moi je m'en fiche est complètement
donc j'écrivais des chansons tout court
le jour où ça les a dérangés mais j'ai
arrêté d'en écrire bête tout bêtement
mais c'est pas un long fleuve tranquille
cette relation avec les artistes là vous
vous nous parler est-ce que d'automne ce
n'était pas une commençant qui a vu
fâcherie qui annonce déjà pas eu de free
une incompréhension mais ça ça arrive
c'était arrivé régulièrement on ne
poursuivait pas le même but moi j'écris
des chansons pour le public elle voulait
écrire des chansons pour les médias et
vous aimez écrire pour le retour des
artistes ça j'adorais ça parce qu'il ya
un côté tu y arriveras pas qui me plaît
beaucoup beaucoup de challenger défi
ouais surtout que un artiste c'est un
personnage attachant en général
99 fois sur 100 c'est quelqu'un qu'on a
envie d'aider des mets de porter de quel
retour vous êtes le plus fier plein
c'est jérôme parce que c'était un garçon
délicieux dans la vie
gilbert montagné parce que je laime 500
hommes c'est un grand musicien et c'est
un type formidable dans la vie aussi
demis roussos parce que c'était une star
internationale et surtout parce qu'on
m'avait dit que j'y arriverai pas
j'adore dès qu'on me dit ça y est moi
j'avais dit que vous aviez aussi écrit
pour bernard tapie on va écouter aussi
un vrai homme avait dit ne le fais pas
tu te rends pas compte tu vas brûler ta
carrière mais on va se passer ouais t'es
tu chantes parfaitement bien ils sont
très très bien en écoute
dans son
ans
sans ça
ok
[Musique]
c'est une chanson intitulée risque sa
vie et ses chansons où il raconte
comment il peut donner des conseils à
des jeunes et des moins jeunes ou tout
bêtement
pourquoi enfin à quoi ça correspond pour
lui de réussir sa vie mais j'avais fait
ça
comment dire moi j'adorais ce personnage
gta
j'aimais ce côté
incontrôlable et incontrôlée quoi qu'il
était et
je me disais je verra mais sûrement au
studio je m'en foutais je méritais le
calepin non je ferai ça deux phrases par
deux phrases non ils savaient vraiment
chanter j'ai fait trois prises de cette
chanson pas plus non elle chantait comme
un chanteur et l'ingénieur qui était
avec moi pareil il était sur le cul in
di meo avant la séance est libre se
préparer à des montages extraordinaire
j'ai dit je sais pas j'ai jamais
entendue chanter et il a pris à hisser
mille casques j'ai encore plein de
photos de cette séance d'enregistrement
et ils chantaient dans la cuisine parce
qu'on trouvait que la chambre de déco de
reverb était meilleure dans la cuisine
on avait tous câblés il enregistrait
dans une cuisine au dessus de nice à
saint-andré les alpes dans un petit
village réussir sa vie c'est le titre de
la chanson vous pensez que vous l'avez
réussi votre vie ou
à c'est une bonne question ça est-ce que
j'ai repris ce que ça veut dire qu'est
ce que ça veut dire réussir sa vie
je sais pas moi de le dire
disons que moi j'ai été
je trouvais quand même que j'étais un
privilégié où avec j'avais de la chance
et que
j'avais entre mes envies ou mes rêves
d'adolescents c'est ma vie d'adulte n'y
avait pas eu d'interférence ce qui
se passait du lycée aux séances
d'enregistrement
tous ces titres continuent de vous
rapporter de l'argent j'en parle parce
que vous l'évoquez vous même de façon
c'est tout répond ça j'avais déjà eu de
la chance j'ai privilégié j'ai toujours
bien vécu deux mondes de votre
composition travail devait composer sur
vous avait dit un jour en 2009 dans une
interview au parisien
tous ces titres on me rapporte encore
beaucoup d'argent on est à ce moment là
en 2009 à celles qui arrivent en tête de
loin c'est les sunlights des tropiques
toujours diffusée dans les fêtes elle
doit générer 100 mille euros de droits
d'auteur par an ça n'a pas changé ça n'a
pas changé non peut-être la baisser un
peu en
je regarde plus alors bon c'est celle
qui vous rapporte le plus ah oui j'en
suis sûr à l'époque je m'intéressais
beaucoup enfin quelques fois beaucoup
mais j'étais curieux de voir qu'on
quelle chanson rapportaient de l'argent
quelques chansons rapporte pas et puis
aujourd'hui avec les nouveaux
comme en
soit ça sur des applications des
applications des ordinateurs des machins
donc je m'en occupe plus du tout je m'en
fous royalement
ce ma femme qui reçoit tous âges je
demande juste si je peux m'acheter une
nouvelle voiture ou pas alors ça ça
change un peu d'une autre époque où vous
aviez décrit un rapport presque indécent
à l'argent parce que j'en gagnais
beaucoup ouais je vous cite vous disiez
j'achetais des mercedes des pianos comme
des pains au chocolat cinq guitares d'un
coup une fois avec christophe on a
débarqué chez porsche il avait les
biftons dans les poches on a ouvert sa
mère le blouson on avait coincé et des
billets de banque en effet fermé le truc
chou il a mis l'argent comme ça sur le
bureau à ces années 70 on était on avait
droit d'aller à la banque chercher des
espèces est payé en espèces est ce que
vous diriez que c'était une période de
tous les excès et que c'était bien je
sais pas c'était une période de tous les
plaisirs en tout cas je peux vous dire
c'est pas si c'était des excès mais
aussi avec l'argent sur le compte on
allait chercher l'argent si la banque
avait des espèces souvent les abeilles
en tout cas pour acheter une voiture en
la payant en liquide ont négocié le prix
parce que il nous prenait pour des gîtes
en arriver nos liasses de billets c'est
génial parce que moi dans ces années là
j'étais pas connu physiquement j'étais
connue que de la profession et vous
aimiez cette sensation j'adorais
j'adorais un jour je suis allée acheter
une voiture que je me souviens arpajon
le type il n'avait pas voulu et me
croyais tellement pas qu'il n'avait pas
sorti de la vitrine on éteint samedi
matin et il avait dû me prendre pour un
mythe au téléphone et/ou et j'arrivais
le garage allait fermer et je vois ma
voiture dans la vitrine je me dis
monsieur sur le monsieur que vous avez
téléphoné
pour la voiture
la volkswagen gti je me souviens à
l'époque c'était une des premières en
france à mg dire non mais comme c'est le
prix il me prend pour un bénin mais
j'étais sapé comme aujourd'hui j'ai
toujours été très mal habillés à
l'époque c'était en par quatre chats ses
cheveux jusqu'à enfin bref cauchemar et
je dis mais j'ai l'argent monsieur oui
il faut me sortir la voiture et je vais
je sors et le mec joie il commença à
paneer parce que peut-être il se dit je
vends ma voiture un gangster et je
voyais qu'il me regardait bizarrement et
je lui dis non mais faut pas vous
affoler je suis un type qui écrit des
chansons et là j'ai fait quelques succès
en trois quatre ans ça suffisait pas
dire je suis didier barbelivien est
nommé personne ce live et des barbelés
viens et je lui dis mon nom et il s'en
fout complètement le vendeur de voiture
vous prenez une revanche qui avait un
petit air de revanche là dedans
non parce qu'au moyen d'un milieu
tellement modeste non justement non
j'avais pas de revanche à prendre avec
la vie j'aurais pu rester dans mon
milieu modeste et je ne serai pas plein
outre mesure ce que je voulais c'était
être heureux je voulais pas être riche
et tout ça je n'aurais rien à
mais
ça procure et des plaisirs quand même et
je n'oublierai jamais pendant que je
comptais mais biftons fifa il va au
téléphone il appelle à la maison chez
lui sa femme et il lui dit tu connais un
type s'appelle didier barbelés comment
vous appelez y avait du mal à dire non
gilles barbelivien et ce quoi les
chansons déjà j'ai michelle le normand
petite fille du soleil christophe romane
et la janis nette zéro enfin je vous
cite cinq ou six et sa femme l acheter
les disques victimes et il est là il est
dans le oui alors il m'a demandé ma
pièce d'identité quand même et tout est
donc ils étaient ébahis de me voir
fameux voire de savoir que j'existais
que j'étais si jeune parce que j'avais
quoi
22 ans et qu'il s'était bien trompé j'ai
une archive à vous montrer didier
barbelivien ch vous je vous laisse entre
les mains je la décris pour les gens qui
nous écoutent un gendre est actionnaire
les archives nationales est une copie du
décret de la convention nationale du 23
août 1793 et c'est ce document qui
lèvera une armée nationale pour
combattre les choix et éradiquer leur
cours de l'année du 10 août mais là je
fais qu évidemment à votre album vendée
car andré 4 avait écrit composé produit
en 92 ou vous retracer les épisodes
cette guerre de vendée mais vu du côté
des choix qu'est ce qui vous a séduit
dans cette bataille dans la contre
révolution le côté cape et épée et puis
le côté les causes perdues moi j'aime
bien les causes perdues je suis rarement
du côté des vainqueurs même
c'est drôle parce que
on m'a toujours donné des tic est d'un
type de droite ce que je dois être sur
nous quelque part mais j'ai toujours été
du côté du
des plus démunis - et de celui qui
revendique une identité une culture
non pas spécialement
j'étais du côté des et comment dire
des des plus modestes le cd pack 1 de
jeu j'ai beaucoup d'affinités d'amitié
de relations avec le monde paysan
voiliers et je dis pas les les
agriculteurs pour moi c'est le monde
paysan et les chouans c'était un peu la
province contre paris aussi c'est
quelque chose web ouais c'est vrai et
puis le panache les gens qui voulaient
se battre contre les armées de la
révolution et puis j'aimais pas trop
c'est vrai
les révolutionnaires j'ai trouvé un peu
expéditif pas spécialement
c'était un peu brutaux quoi et vous vous
êtes un contre-révolutionnaire
non mais peut-être dans ces années là
ouais j'aurais été du côté des choix
sûrement
alors l'histoire vous a inspiré et puis
vous rencontrent aussi vous en avez déjà
un petit peu parlé ces rencontres vous
en avez fait un livre une galerie
portrait qui s'appelle pleure pas
nostalgique comme chez elles ne sont pas
tous là mais un bon gars ya charles
aznavour il ya coluche à belmondo il ya
deux par dieu vous êtes tourné vers le
passé vous avez une forme de nostalgie
d'une d'une certaine époque
non j'ai toujours été comme ça
aujourd'hui encore
voyez j'ai la nostalgie de la rue de
tournon l'unc et à ma droite
mais je vous je vous dirai jamais quelle
nostalgie en fait ce pas une nostalgie
mois la nostalgie chez moi c'est un
film-enquête passe à l'envers voyez ce
que je veux dire je me pose pas la
question du c'était mieux avant mais
c'est juste que quand je vais vous vous
regardez la rue de tournon comme une rue
de paris peut-être et moi je vois
d'autres lumières d'autres personnes
d'autres voitures garées ça vous paraît
peut-être bizarre et dire vous voyez je
vois pas ce qu'il ya ce que j'ai sous
les yeux
souvent je vois autre chose que ce qu'on
me montre vous voyez les gens vous avez
croisés si c'est ça ma boîte exactement
je vois d'autres visages doter d'autres
c'est pour ça que j'aime bien paris pas
ce pari de
l'architecturé change peut donc je
retrouve plein de
commandes pleins de relations entre les
pierres et mon regard notre dossier vous
c'est pas celle de michel sardou qui
nous dit joel notre époque c'est de la
merde on ne peut plus conduire vite on
ne peut plus boire plus fumer c'est pas
votre nostalgie à vous ça non parce que
moi je bois je fume et je conduis vite
l'europe
et cette époque des communications
modernes on parlait avant l'émission du
téléphone portable est ce que vous êtes
un peu réfractaires à ce changement là à
ces nouvelles technologies non j'aurais
adoré être un génie de la nouvelle
technologie de
dalle et sur les marchés boursiers du
monde entier avec des trucs en cliquant
des trucs mais moi je m'en contrefous de
ces appareils là c'est ça m'a jamais
intéressé mais de même bien avant c'est
à dire que
je savais pas me servir d'un je sais pas
moi d'un
d'un vélomoteur normalement c'est à dire
si la bougie s'encrasser où tout ça je
savais même pas où il fallait tourner le
truc
techniquement j'ai toujours été une buse
donc
je suis commandes très très étrange et à
la technologie bizarre un jour je me
suis arrêté je me souviens des stations
service avec ma voiture et je voulais
chez plus quoi qu'on vérifie l'huile et
je trouvais pas comme on ouvrait le
capot et le type à l'époque ce pas
restée d'un époque de ma jeunesse où
j'étais d'un godet des voitures de sport
et mis un moment il me regardait mais
elle est à vous la voiture vous êtes
sûre ils ne vivent saipa comment s ouvre
sinon monsieur juste faire de ces
mesures je connais rien j'ai la clé de
contact
je cède à conduire je crois et ma foi
non je sais pas et si on fait le
parallèle avec votre musique vous la
faites aussi comme un artisan avec votre
guitare et point bas oui je j'écris avec
le des guitares sèches
et des pianos droits peut céder petit
piano enfin les canaux normaux
je voudrais qu'on parle de vous de façon
un petit peu plus personnel vous avez
dit un jour je ne parle jamais de mon
enfant ça n'a aucun intérêt je parle
plus de mon adolescence avant j'étais un
tube digestif
ça m'a beaucoup fait rire en deçà c'est
pourtant oui vous avez dit ça pourtant
il ya eu une enfance riche vous avez
quand même grandi en afrique c'est ça au
congo en france comment dire oui comment
on peut appeler ça
un peu
trimbalé mais j'ai détesté être un
enfant je détestais mon état d'enfants
pourquoi je m'ennuyais je trouvais le
g mais pas du tout je ne m'aimais pas
moi j'aimais pas des autres enfants fin
c'était un cauchemar que c'était un
enfant solitaire
je déteste être avec les autres je vous
avais compris pourquoi avec non je
n'étais que dans les livres
je sais pas j'étais quelqu'un de
réfractaires à
un jeu d'enfant je vais trouver
complètement débile
était un adolescent très heureux en fait
j'ai commencé à aimer la vie vraiment à
15 ans 14 15 ans mais ce passage par
l'afrique se par le congo c'est regarder
des séries atari mais c'était pas des
souvenirs
comment dire fascinant quand on est un
enfant en afrique où quand on est
contraint plutôt que libre parce qu'il
ya plein de danger parce que le souvient
mon père m'avait expliqué qu'un jeune
homme ait trouvé en train de jouer avec
un scorpion du mahdi bon ces moyens ont
heureusement qu'on est arrivé au bon
moment mais ouais
gtg mais passe à l'enfance j'aimais pas
l'autorité déjà j'aimais pas fais pas ci
fais pas ça ça me fatiguait vous aviez
hâte de vous réaliser en tant que non je
veux qu'on me foute la paix surtout jeu
après je partais vivre chez ma grand
mère
puisque je m'entendais plus avec mes
parents et
j'étais heureux dans le en fait dans le
libéralisme de ma grand mère qui me
laissait tout faire jeter son idole j'en
profite et passe je faisais pas trop le
con quand même vous les chantiers des
chansons et oui tout de suite tout de
suite dès que j'ai fait mes premières
chansons celles qui étaient entendus
c'est mon premier public bond a été très
indulgente comme jeter son petit-fils et
où est-ce que 15 16 ans c'est l'âge où
vous faites aussi repéré vous commencez
à vous faire repérer ça va très vite ça
va très vite mais peut-être j'ai dû
commencer à écrire j'avais 14 ans 15 ans
je fais tout en même temps je me dis bon
si ça plaît ma grand-mère dessus des
pères directeur artistique puisque ma
grand mère près tout le web ou à l'est
mais les chanteurs de l'époque enfin
bref elles étaient être représentative
d'un certain public justement est la
preuve pierre comment elle me donnait
son avis était drôle elle intervenait
quoi
elle vous disais quoi parler que son
accent d'auvergnats parce qu'elle était
lozérienne et elle avait l'accent un peu
qui roulait comme ça
sans vous dire pourquoi bah non il n'y a
pas besoin de dire pourquoi pour les
chansons on les aime on les aime pas ce
pas c'est pas grave c'est juste
j'ai des photos aussi pour vous ôter
barbelivien
celle-ci ben on ne craignait nicolas
sarkozy oui
jour celui que vous considérez comme
votre frère ouais c'est vrai parce que
j'ai des rapports on a un rapport
familiale depuis 40 ans qui s'est
derrière atteint escroquent ce que bien
non
devedjian même sa direction reconnaît
patrick devedjian si j'adorais aussi
patrick dejean c'était un homme très
cultivé très intelligent ouais nicolas
c'est une histoire qui s'est fait
naturellement je devrais je pas où on
est d'accord qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce
qu'il ya
j'aime sa spontanéité j'aime sa vérité
j'aime ces erreurs j'aime ses défauts
j'aime ses qualités il me plaît vous
allez je déduis encore aujourd'hui à
très très très il est sans filtre un peu
comme moi j'aime bien vous
tranquillement que la france au monde
politique aujourd'hui l'essentiel où
j'allais dire égoïstement c'est qu'ils
me manquent pas à moi mais
mais
peut-être ou et peut-être y manque enfin
il a pragmatisme une facilité de
faire la synthèse des choses qui
manquent un peu sûrement ouais vous
parler politique avec lui vous savez ça
nous ça nous arrive non quand on parlait
politique ou quand il nous arrive de
parler politique
c'est sur un fait une action précise
voyez
peut-être si je le vois ce week-end je
lui dire tu crois que c'est bien la
finlande et la suède aux portes de
l'otan le russe cov comment il va
prendre de l'histoire à ton avis gypsy
toi tu l'a rencontré au moment de l'acte
et 0 6 1 oui
venez-y
nicolas il l'a rencontrée à ce moment là
pour éviter quand même un très mauvais
sort à
à cette province de géorgie est violent
et il m'avait fait rire c'est pas secret
je peux le dire
je sais pas si lui l'a déjà dit sur des
plateaux de télévision
j'ai dit mais comment tu as fait pour le
convaincre se ce type là de lâcher la
géorgie il me dit c'est que les chars
étaient rentrés dans le rang la ville
dans la capitale
mbi je lui ai dit voilà monsieur
président c'est simple
si vous retirez pas les chars de la
ville je repars pas et le tu dis comment
ça vous repartez pas mais je vais rester
ici j'irai dormir à l'ambassade de
france je vais rester ici aussi
longtemps qu'il faut et l'autre s'est
dit mme ce possible ils vont penser que
j'ai kidnappé le président français est
du coup il a fait ressortir les chars
tous les chars il lui a dit je ne
partirai pas tant qu'il y aura un char
dans la ville ça a sûrement pas empêché
poutine de les ramener vingt-quatre
heures après mais il l'avait fait plier
il avait quand même obtenu des garanties
de comment dire
de sécurité pour ces gens là c'est déjà
pas mal de garantir la sécurité d'un
dissident une dernière question pour
aller la dernière de l'émission vous
allez adorer j'en suis sûr ces quatre
statues qui nous entoure y'en a une
derrière vous qui représente la sagesse
une autre la prudence une autre la
justice et l'autre l'éloquence est-ce
qu'il y en a une sur laquelle vous avez
envie de d'exprimer quelque chose en
particulier sagesse prudence justice
éloquence je regarde des statues
romaines
la prudence banon ce n'est pas un mec
prudent
la justice non comme des échos lui s'il
y avait une justice dans ce pays ça se
saurait
l'éloquence
peut-être moi je suis plus pour le le
bavardage
la conversation est derrière moi il ya
quoi la sagesse assez ça respire la
sagesse pour ça allait bien dans mon dos
il peut me
protégeait les servir de guide et
protéger ce serait pas mal et elles sont
là au sénat merci
d'avoir joué le jeu et ont jamais dit
qu'il y ait au dos nous tournons je vous
ai parlé sincèrement je pense pas que ce
soit un jeu et le public en sera ravi
merci infiniment d'avoir échoué dans un
monde un regard merci à vous de nous
avoir suivis je suis sûr que ça vous a
plu on se retrouve très vite sur public
sénat
[Musique]